ah ah
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans votre
émission favorite si on parlait sport ce
talk est consacré comme vous le savez à
l'actualité sportive du département
au programme des coups de gueule des
analyses des débats et des duels pour
faire vivre cette émission je serai une
nouvelle fois bien entouré quatre
chroniqueurs passionné de sport
yvelinois sont sur le plateau on
commence les présentations en musique
à ma droite il vient tout droit de la
cité royale de versailles
vous le connaissez forcément si vous
avez suivi la première saison de ce dock
il est à ce jour l'homme qui a remporté
le plus de duels dans cette émission on
le surnomme ici la faucheuse ce sera
notre spécialiste
handball dans ce talk alexandre
taillefer est avec nous pour cette
émission
bonjour à tous ça fait plaisir de
retrouver chacun c'était la première
fois cette année mon planning est un
petit peu changé et je pouvais pas à
venir mais ils ont profité cette fois ci
pour pouvoir honorer cette émission vous
avez manqué à vos fans on a reçu des
dizaines et des dizaines de lettres pour
pour vous un petit mot pour vous
peut-être rapidement supporter et
continue à supporter surtout le club de
versailles le handball pour que puisse
continuer à bien évoluer à bien figurer
prochain c'est le thé on passait notre
deuxième chroniqueurs ou devrais je dire
chroniqueuse c'est l'une des meilleurs
coachs en ile-de-france de kolda
laissez pas séduire par ses yeux en
amande et ses airs de gentille fille
elle n'hésite pas être piquante quand il
le faut notre ambassadrice de charme
hélène de la grange au fait l'honneur de
venir sur cette émission bonjour élèves
ça me fait plaisir
trois démissions oui ça y est voilà vous
êtes parti vous êtes mais oui je crois
qu'on a pu m'arrêter maintenant vous
avez réussi un petit peu les émissions
et j'ai regardé venir on va voir ça de
l'autre côté on retrouve une légende de
cette émission musique on ne le présente
plus les coaches de l'équipe de rugby de
plaisir il n'hésite pas à pousser en
mêlée pour envoyer des blagues quand il
le faut dans vous dire qu'on a plus de
mal à le garder en plateau tellement les
grandes chaînes de télévision lui font
des ponts d'or pour le recruter genlis
est avec nous car est vraiment il est
beau c'est une rumeur ou pas un jour ou
deux
alors non je ne sais pas honnêtement
j'ai pas eu de contact au moins oral
téléphone et la non non non allez ce
soir car elle plaisir et c'est sur ce
taux qui s'est quand même un réel
plaisir d'être ici parmi vous on termine
par un spécialiste de cricket l'un des
sports les plus pratiqués pour monde
c'est invivable chroniqueur ne vais pas
envoyer des punchlines pour le surnomme
dans cette élection
le special one robinho gafi club de
cricket de thoiry est avec nous
le cricket bonjour est à l'honneur
aujourd'hui du coup dans cette émission
c'est super c'est super je suis content
d'être de retour dans une fois plus
c'est bien l'un des sports les plus
populaires au monde
absolument je pensais deuxième scorpa le
plus populaire en france mais non non
non mais il ya des pays où est beaucoup
plus de monde qu'en france si on peut le
faire dans les yvelines
on peut le faire dans les yvelines peut
le faire 3 et surtout un sport qui se
pratique de plus en plus en france
alors avant de vous présenter les thèmes
de l'émission j'aimerais qu'on parle de
golf à un peu moins de 100 jours du
début de la ryder cup 2018 qui
soutiendra je vous le rappelle sur les
greens du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'organisation
vient de désigner son ambassadeur et
c'est le navigateur armel le cléac'h qui
a été choisi pour incarner cette
fonction à symbolique qu'on écoute la
réaction du dernier vainqueur du vendée
globe
une fierté notre ambassadeur pour la
ryder cup en france l'année prochaine on
a besoin en france d'avoir des
compétitions comme ça de
de niveau mondial ne renommée
internationale pour justement donné des
vocations
des jeunes des moins jeunes pour jouer
au golf parce qu on se rend compte que
effectivement c'est un sport que l'on
peut pratiquer à tous niveaux
alors quelle est votre réaction par
rapport à cette nomination
j'en lis je vous ai vu discuter pendant
l'interview non je suis avec le cléac'h
qui a gagné le dernier vendée globe une
course de voile way ses proches du golfe
il fait du gol oui oui j'espère j'espère
enfin parce que c'est un homme ça me sur
3 un peu quand même surprenant c'est
tout parce que je sais pas on n'a pas
une ni deux figures emblématiques dans
le milieu du golf français pour être
représentant 200 les gradins ce temps
l'équipe
oui certainement mais il ya eu d'abord
un nom mais pas actuelle que déchirure
des figures des anciens moi ça me choque
un petit peu qu'on prenne un ambassadeur
d'un autre sport quoi c'est tout je
conseille ce fait plus en plus quand
même c'est vrai on prend les gens qui
sont connus plus que connu pour le sport
on a fait décoller la voile sur que non
mais on veut que les gens d'en bas c'est
de l'antre 2002 c'était bécane pour le
football donc qu'il ait rien avoir vu
neiger de l'interdiction de ce sport là
c'est vraiment le golf ou alors à dire
que donc voilà ouais non mais ce serait
peut-être mieux mais je pense qu'ils ont
pris parce qu'il est très cher ça serait
une belle image vraiment de de l'avoir
lui sur les greens pour pour le coup
d'envoi de cette ryder cup avec le
bateau peut être un sport avec le bateau
à genlis un peu plus proche peut-être
que
que le la voix j'aurais pensé au tennis
plutôt moi mais bon après je parle à
voix haute ou certaines c'est très
éloigné du golfe quoi pour nos coûts là
c'est un peu surprenant je trouve
d'avoir choisi quelqu'un qui fait de la
voix les aurais mois et demi qui avait
vraiment personne à mettre de très
emblématique pour que ce soit reconnu
en internationale on aurait pu
éventuellement m apparemment l'idée ça
me venaient un tennisman mais bon après
peut-être autre chose alors
éventuellement cas ce qu'on le croise
auteur david douillet qui est des
yvelines et qui aurait été certainement
beaucoup plus connu un jeu j'ai rien
quant à l'autre je suis peut-être plus
de la politique maintenant peut-être
peut-être mais c'est une figure on va
dire c'est une figure du sport français
en général et je suis pas sûr quand même
que la voilà c'est vraiment le sport le
plus populaire quand même est-ce que ça
sert vraiment à quelque chose finalement
hélène qui un ambassadeur pour cette
ryder cup
elle se vend tout seul finalement c'est
travailleurs plus oui c'est sûr après le
fait d'avoir quand même quelqu'un qui
représente par son image par les gens
aiment bien avoir une personne à
regarder une personne à suivre peut-être
même parfois dépôt temps des trucs
peut-être qu'ils auraient pu prendre
aussi quelqu'un qui est pas forcément
issus du sport est une célébrité ou
quelque chose qui rassemble un peu plus
de monde et qui crée pas spécialement un
débat entre les différentes disciplines
la voile le golf soit et que ça ça rien
à voir donc
non ne convenait pas vraiment fan si je
comprends bien on n'a jamais vu ça si
louise ouvertement de l'oraison aussi on
n'aura pas trop poser de question ne
leur a pas posé de vrais en raison d'une
raison qu on leur posera sûrement droit
dans les prochains
quand vous apportera la réponse
aujourd'hui on va passer maintenant au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de baseball et de la très
belle saison des cougars de montigny le
bretonneux vous évoqueront également la
réussite sportive de la ville de plaisir
cette année la commune enregistre la
montée de deux équipes nous allons
essayer de décrypter ces résultats mais
avant de développer ces thèmes coup de
projecteur sur l'incroyable combat du
boxeur à marvin petit
[Musique]
l'élan courtois marvin petit n'a pas
tremblé ce jeudi à 18 mai pour remporter
son tout premier titre de l'union
européenne dans la catégorie des poids
légers à seulement 26 ans le sportif
yves binois s'est imposé au cirque
d'hiver de paris contre l'espanyol 0
baie sainte anne a pourtant invaincu
jusqu'à présent
bref un petit l'homme qui a terminé 43%
de ses combats par ko à cette fois ci dû
attendre la décision des juges pour
s'imposer s'imposer aux points
il affiche désormais un palmarès digne
des plus grands boxeurs de l'hexagone
avec deux titres de champion de france
et un titre européen
on écoute les réactions un très bon bras
fait que j'ai mis une stratégie en place
vous fallait que je reste sérieux déjà
obligatoire donc ça c'était un truc que
fallait que je sois concentré à toulon
du combat et j'ai tenu ma promesse de
rester sérieux et le travail a payé marc
brunel a fait preuve d'intelligence
il a été très intelligent sang froid et
asus contrôle il s'est pas énervé et ça
a payé
disons qu'en le programme pour qu'il
soit dix fois champion du monde un jour
c'est sûr
alors on espère qu'ils aient un jour it
et élise le titre mondial
hélène vous aviez une petite réaction
par rapport à la ceinture de marine
petit j'ai bien aimé la fierté a montré
super belle ceinture donc c'est tu peux
comprendre il ya du travail tout ça donc
je veux comprendre qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient fiers mais c'est très c'est très
masculin vous montrer ses trophées comme
ça me fait sourire
alors selon nos informations l'espanyol
0 b à santana serait reparti en espagne
avec une fracture de la mâchoire et le
nez cassé
je le disais précédemment son palmarès à
26 ans est remarquable deux titres de
champion de france et un titre de
l'union européenne la question sur ce
thème peut-il aller encore plus haut oui
ou non voter oui non vous êtes unanimes
sur la question
robin pourquoi je pense qu'il peut aller
il ya plus loin franchement le box des
frais non pas le sport que j'aime que
chez précis mais je pense que
il est jeune il est champion de france
il ya plein de possibilités
[Musique]
pourquoi pas mais y gpad avait eu elles
très étrange et là dessus je suis loin
d'être export de beauté experts de boxe
mais oui pourquoi pas il a déjà fait un
pas de patois pas pourquoi pas le reste
il résiste en france europe il est jeune
en six ans c'est très jeune dans la boxe
on continue largement ce qu'il a 40 ans
pour gagner des titres
donc voilà pourquoi ils n'auraient pas
toutes ses chances il reste au moins dix
bonnes années pour devenir son tour du
monde donc pour moi il a le temps de
continuer à progresser et puis pour
l'instant il lisse il continue à gagner
donc je vois pas pourquoi ils pourraient
pas à viser plus haut après la question
qui se pose c'est une ville plus au camp
voilà c'est à partir de quand il pense
alors le jeu plonge combat de martin
petit serait logiquement dans six sept
mois à peu près pour une défense de
titre et le titre mondial ne serait pas
avant un an et demi deux ans mais je
prends ma place en valeur je pense que
c'est une démarche nos voisins mais je
pense que c'est une bonne chose je pense
qu'il faut pas sucré les étapes je pense
qu'il faut qu'il continue à livrer des
combats
difficile mais pas forcément impossible
immédiatement et que avec l'assurance de
la confiance qu'ils vont engranger avec
des décès combat qui qui sont au même
niveau qu il vient de gagner il va
pouvoir avoir plus de chance pour gagner
un titre mondial
vous êtes d'accord avec alexandre gens
ont eu tous bonifie avec l'âge dans la
boxe voulons prendre expérience c'est un
sport où il s'adonne une hormone
d'expérience et 26 ans et ses très
jeunes comme l'a dit alexandre et ce qui
est aussi c'est que c'était l'espagnol
qui avait fait faux bond au dernier
moment c'est ça il avait fait un bon
deux jours avant de voir le mois de
janvier il avait fait faux bond à ses
bienfaits avant la double fracture les
espérions lignes ramassées avec nos
boxeurs français et raul sur la il vous
dirait je veux le dire pour lui c'est
accor mauxion de la team farruggia c'est
un boxeur natif à rogers en reparlera
justement un peu plus loin dans ce
championnat où le pour toi raoult qui
n'a pas pu venir malheureusement sur
cette émission à cause d'un contrôle
anti dopage de ces chevaux et je vous
rappelle qu'il est cavalier
international
alors c'est un avantage ou un
désavantage dans la boxe pour marvin
petit d'être d'être jeune finalement
l'ailier dans un âge où il faut aller
vite où il faut aller lentement en fait
non justement je pense que pour moi il
faut qu'il prenne le temps de demain de
soigner sa box est d'arriver au plus
haut niveau et
deux armes deux ânes c'est bien et ça
lui laisse justement si vous dites qu'il
a un combat dans sept mois
mais ça lui laisse le temps de se
préparer pour défendre sa sa ceinture
d'europe et ensuite
et s'il a des fins et si la conserve il
pourra envisager d'aller chercher un
titre mondial qu un titre suprême un
titre mondial après alexandre taillefer
il a connu seulement une seule défaite
en 23 combats depuis qu'il est
professionnel
mais au final la boxe ça joue sur des
détails des fois sur un combat sa
carrière peut se briser sur un combat on
redescend tout en bas de l'échelle de la
boxe est pas pouvoir rebondir justement
récompense une passe dans un échelon où
il faut qu'on attende qu' une autre
chance qui se présente à nous en sachant
qu'à côté il ya des gens qui ne font que
gagner qui passeront devant nous donc
c'est pour ça qu'il faut c'est des
bruits à ne pas perdre pour ne pas
perdre il faut peut-être pas se livrer
un combat trop dur trop tôt je pense
qu'il faut qu'il prenne le temps de
grimper les échelons papa l'espagnol
aurait robes et santana n'était pas non
plus un novice un vraiment dans ce
combat c'est il avait remporté tout
c'est tout c'est tout c'est tous ces
cons balladur ou un an durant sa
carrière il mettait il était invaincu
comme je disais précédemment
finalement ce combat ça va l'aider à
grandir encore plus marvin petit il a
travaillé tout au long du combat pour
obtenir la victoire face à un adversaire
redoutable
est-ce que ça va l'aider à grandir mais
de toute façon chaque adversaire
différent donc on apprend vraiment il ya
comme disait jean il ya vraiment une
expérience qui se crée une maturité et
une maturité aussi dans les techniques
et et même une gestion du stress que pas
du tout la mène la préparation elle va
être de plus en plus plus en plus
précises plus en plus
comment dire oui et puis orienté vers
tel ou tel titre
la i gagne là dans quelques mois y voilà
il ya de nouveau un combat pour
maintenir sa touche chaque combat compte
et voilà c'est dans la confiance comme
vous disiez dans vraiment la maturité et
voilà ci prend son temps qui travaille
bien et que oui après ses faux pas faut
pas se reposer sur ses lauriers faut
continuer à travailler pas brûler les
arbitres et on a déjà dit mais voilà ça
comme ça compte
alors un autre boxeur de la team
farruggia s'est illustré son nom à
gallus coulon ce vendredi 19 mai à dreux
le trappistes de 26 ans remporter un
combat international contre le slovaque
ivan gaudord un champion du monde de
pieds poings le sportif il vinuales a
battu aux points il affiche désormais un
bilan de 7 victoires 1 nul et huit
défaites on écoute la réaction de son
entraîneur à l'inévitable tanguy à faro
jean pascal a fait la différence gallus
ils étaient affûtés et puis après il
s'est énervé un petit peu parce que
l'adversaire était truqueurs mais sinon
voilà il a prouvé qu'il était plus
intelligent et nous présenterons à dire
robin comment expliquer cette réussite
de ce club a dit labeaume a dit champion
d'europe
marvin petit champion d'europe gallus
colons qui remportent des combats
international et y en a d'autres qui
arrivent derrière c'est aujourd'hui
peut-être le meilleur club de boxe en
france
quelle est la recette pour que ça
fonctionne j'ai l'impression que cet
entraîneur y est pour quelque chose
je pense que quand on a un leader
quelqu'un qui sait motiver les les
autres boxeurs ça c'est des jeunes
éléments qui est important et puis plus
il ya de succès et s'amène du succès
donc c'est un ou deux qui gagne les eaux
ils vont attirer peut-être d'autres
personnes qui croient et yeux je pense
que ça fait 1
un mouvement positif a essayé on a
quelqu'un à la tête ou plusieurs qui
savent fait manipuler tous et bonne
chose
c'est peut-être pour ça que cette
progresse c'est dur à gérer
j'en lis également d'avoir plusieurs
boxeurs sous contrat la boxe est un
sport à part quand même hein c'est quand
même un sport assez particulier qui
demande beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'investissement personnel et de travail
c'est des heures et des heures et des
heures de travail on dit que tous les
sports haut niveau demande énormément
d'heures de travail de préparation et
d'entraînement
mais la boxe particulièrement ces sports
guy qui demande quand même une grande
résistance physique puisque après vers
les comores d'ailleurs on ne sait pas où
les fonctions ne sont pas beaucoup de
commandes dans l'année on le sait donc
c'est pas pour rien
il ya beaucoup de préparation pour très
peu de temps de combat finalement le
travail est fragile a peut-être avec
cendres taillefer se diriger le travail
est fragile dans la boxe il peut
s'écouler dans cinq ou ce travail par
rapport à oui parce que comme il ya très
peu de compétition inévitablement on n'a
pas beaucoup d'occasions de se montrer
et comme une hiérarchie qui se crée avec
ceux qui gagnent victoire après victoire
on peut monter en échelon
partitionnement on a une défaite donc
presque repartir quasiment de zéro donc
du coup donc là aujourd'hui en lançant
ce temps guy farrugia mais finalement
peut-être dans six 6 mois 1 an tout le
monde pour aller tourner dessus
non parce qu'à mon avis il a
suffisamment de boxer pour continuer à
gagner
dans tous les cas je pense mais c'est à
l'échelle d'une carte un boxeur ou la
problématique peut se peut se retrouver
palais celle d'un club je pense que le
club comme dans une voie maintenant où
ils ont suffisamment de boxeurs de
qualité pour maintenir ce niveau là
après chaque bosseur on le souhaite
évidemment toujours gagner mais
malheureusement un moment donné il y en
a qui perdront et ça sera plus compliqué
pour eux mais je pense que l'ensemble de
la team continuera à fonctionner et à
mon avis à se bonifier parce que comme
dit robin je pense que le succès
entraîne le succès déjà au niveau de la
confiance qu'on peut accorder à son
entraîneur au lieu de d'entraînement aux
méthodes d'entraînement et puis aussi
attirer
des boxeurs qui ont les qualités et qui
croient qu'ils vont avoir
l'investissement nécessaire pour gagner
je pense ça fait effet boule de neige
tout ça le temps imparti sur ce thème
est terminée on continue cette page
résultats par du baseball les cougars de
montillot bretons n'en finissent plus de
gagner lésigny montain viennent
d'enchaîner leur sixième victoire
consécutive dans le championnat de
première division
leur victime du week-end des arvernes de
clermont ferrand les cougars l'ont
emporté 9 à 0 et 3 à 2 au classement la
roma tabac est en marche mon pti bretons
ne prend une sérieuse option sur la
troisième place et pourrait viser la
deuxième place d'ici la fin du
championnat on écoute
l'entraîneur de l'équipe on va rester
serein on va garder la tête froide aient
encore beaucoup de matches la saison ne
fait que commencer et on va on va
prendre les matches un par un et on
garde le même objectif c'est rester en
milieu de tableau alors pour réaliser
les objectifs fixés par le club
montigny-le-bretonneux a effectué un
recrutement en adéquation avec ses
ambitions
ces derniers jours deux japonais ont
rejoint à l'effectif il ya également le
retour d'une certaine la milice à mes
yeux une joueuse formé au club et qui
est de mieux en 2015 la première femme
de l'histoire à intégrer l'européenne
leigh campe dirigé par la mlb
l'équivalent de la première division
américaine de baseball nous avons
rencontré quelques recrues en fait j'ai
été sélectionné au sport études à
toulouse au creps il ya trois ans et du
coup j'ai du bas j'ai voulu trouver un
club de d1 pour pour perfectionner les
entraînements et les matchs du moose et
mes parents ont déménagé à perpignan et
du coup j'ai j'ai été joué pour
montpellier pendant deux ans et
là comme l'équipe de montigny revient en
province
ça me permet de revenir aux sources ça
me fait super plaisir parce que je
retrouve un peu tout le monde c'est ça a
toujours été comme ma famille montigné
alors je retrouve tous les coaches qui
m'ont vu quand j'étais petit je suis
souvent avec mon frère du coup ça me
laisse l'occasion d'avoir plus de temps
avec le hamas était passé important pour
moi mon premier but cette année est de
gagner le championnat de france
personnellement j'aimerais faire une
bonne saison pour jouer aux états unis
montigny-le-bretonneux promis cette
saison peut donc viser le titre en fin
de saison avec l'aide de ses recrues la
question sur ce thème le recrutement
est-il l'élément le plus important pour
réussir sa saison le recrutement est-il
l'élément le plus important pour réussir
sa saison
j'insiste sur l'élément le plus
important le plus important vous êtes
partagés ont fait un petit duel entre
robin et alexandre taillefer
par exemple vous commencez alors
je gémis j'étais que ses gimmicks se
départager parce que il ya deux raisons
c'est sûr que sans une bonne équipe on
ne peut pas gagner ça c'est une
certitude donc le recrutement en ce sens
là est important
très important maintenant si le
recrutement affecte l'ambiance générale
du groupe
il peut malgré le fait qu'il soit bon
entraîné plus de défaites que s'il
n'avait pas eu lieu donc la difficulté
c'est combien de recrues à mon avis pas
trop pour laisser de la place aux
joueurs qui étaient qui étaient là
actuellement et de qualité par rapport
au fonctionnement du groupe c'est-à-dire
recrutés là où il ya vraiment des
manques et puis faire attention au
caractère des recrues pour qu'ils
puissent correctement
s'intégrer dans
dans le groupe actuel robin ouais je
suis d'accord qu'il faut faire attention
m je pensais particules baseball par
rapport à d'autres sports s'effraye que
recrue rien de jeu une partie du jeu qui
très individuelle dans le baseball donc
ses frais de l'esprit d'équipé il faut
pas des méga stars qui sont pas sympas
avec les autres qui veut dominer mais
même temps dans le jeu de baseball il
est possible d'avoir un joueur
exceptionnel qui quasiment tout seul il
peut fait gagner des matchs donc pour le
baseball
c'est trop bête non plus important les
recrues que dans l'année comme frey jeu
d'équipé football où il faut que le
nouveau joue vraiment tous les jours et
à chaque instant avec la reste l'équipe
taille des moments dans le baseball ou
si on est un batteur exceptionnel
on entre sur le terrain on gagne le
match tout seul soit ils ont des comptes
en est même si c'est un mec pas très
sympa on est quand même content il a
porté le cic plus tôt c'est dans ce sens
là je pensais y voyez on peut avoir des
des stars qui arrivent et qui gagne deux
matches dans les dix premiers minutes et
après on est tranquille pour le reste
tout le reste la journée à regarder pour
les 5 qui reste du match c'est le fun et
donc oui je pense pour le baseball c'est
plus important pour fred un peu plus où
l'équipe est frais - puis menacé c'est
que ça j'aime bien ça le gel de l'équipe
là c'est peut-être moins important mais
pour les couche-tard et kubrick c'est
important de gens qui a raison qui a
tort
je crois que les deux les deux ont
raison les deux ont raison il n'y a pas
une app qui parce que vous voulez des
yvelines c'était pour la politique a pas
du tout plu à tous mais je rejoins les
deux je rejoins les deux parce qu'ils
ont mis son bien défini exactement entre
les disciplines différentes
moi je rajouterais juste
plus par rapport à l'analyse d'alexandre
c'est quand un sport collectif
effectivement moi je suis d'accord avec
lui lorsqu'il dit il faut pas trop de
recrues
parce que le ce qui prime avant tout
c'est le collectif et déjà quand on met
un collectif qui fonctionne si on change
trop d'éléments mais ce collectif là il
faut le refaire donc ça c'est très
important mais je rajouterais juste un
petit bémol à savoir que one bâle comme
au rugby d'ailleurs à des postes clés
parce qu'il ya des postes clés dans ces
disciplines
il est important quand même d'avoir un
joueur avec un petit peu plus
d'expérience et plus ce joueur là est
bon et plus il peut apporter à l'équipe
je pense notamment par exemple ou rugby
un demi d'ouverture avec un excellent
jeu au pied qui va vous m
12 points par match au pied où ces
garanties et c'est très important dans
dans la 92e championnat quoi donc oui du
recrutement oui à des postes clés et pas
trop il a également peut-être un souci
d'intégration hélène avec certains
joueurs
les japonais qui arrive qui débarque à
montigny sans connaître forcément
l'histoire du club
c'est forcément une intégration
différente que celle de mélissa mahut
qui a grandi au club a été formé au club
et qui revient à aux cougars après avoir
passé quelques années à toulouse 0-1
c'est forcément différent il ya déjà
culturel non c'est pas pareil je
historiquement aussi voilà il est comme
tu disais voilà ils connaissent pas
forcément l'historique du club et c'est
maintenant je pense qu'ils arrivent même
de l'étranger ford leur capacité à leur
poste
pour lesquels ont déjà recruté donc
savent au moins faire ça je pense que
tout le monde est assez intelligent pour
laisser la place aux arrivants
et puis qu'ils occupent chacun le leur
comment dire leurs fonctions de façon
confortable on va dire après si tout le
monde a envie de faire avancer vraiment
l'équipe le way d'équiper les îles club
il devrait pas y avoir de problème
d'intégration je pense que si d'office
un joueur est connu pour un très mauvais
caractère un problème d'intégration et
cetera on aura plus de difficulté à plus
de réticence à leurs côtés aussi je
pense que ça doit rentrer en ligne de
compte dans le dans le choix du tout
entraîneur à mon avis auprès des
recruteurs
et est-ce que ça fout ce peut être le
championnat également 2
d'intégrer des japonais des joueurs
d'amérique dans l'équipe avec cette
affaire c'est un discours est ce que
c'est un peu ce pas là un peu le
championnat montant que temps que c'est
autorisé on dit tout ce qui est autorisé
pour pour gagner ils sont produits ici
l'amour vont peut-être viser le titre de
champion de france à la fin de la saison
les autres avec à leurs côtés si si si
si vous voulez être meilleur si pense à
être meilleur avec eux non mais je pense
qu'il ya un règlement on respecte le
règlement on utilise il ya un nombre de
recrues il ya une date pour les recruter
voilà dix ans en attendant le foll il ya
20 ans le foll européen c'était des
différents payer quasiment tous les pays
y avait aucun est joue étrangers
aujourd'hui on voit par exemple en
angleterre où on a le plus mauvaises
équipes nationales d'europe et occasions
+ longueuil qui jouent dans les grands
clubs en angleterre je le regrette pour
les sports de l'histoire du club et tout
ça avec pour le spectacle et
malheureusement pour l'argent pour le
business c'est du business maintenant
temps que les meilleurs joueurs
on paye le prix on a les mêmes joueurs
on a le même spectacle c'est comme ça je
regrette d'une certaine manière mais il
sait comme ça maintenant le sport oui
j'en rapidement oui oui et puis je je je
je rejoins et je redis encore squeeze
tout à l'heure parce que on l'a déjà
citées ici mais par exemple au sous sol
américain il avait recruté un ou deux
américains pas des postes clés parce que
c'est justement ce que disait robin tout
à l'heure il ya certaines disciplines
plus que d'autres où les postes clés
sont très importants mais
obligatoirement quand on a cherché des
joueurs étrangers qui sont des
spécialistes de la discipline
forcément ça fait monter le niveau de
suite le niveau y est ça fait monter le
niveau
2 gagne ou on n'aime pas ces
spécialistes donc ça se sait davantage
le niveau général du pôle nord besoin
d'aller chercher deux jambes fait jouer
j'ai deux japonais ils vont pas aller
chercher de belles jeunes notre notre
cameraman qui en régie doit doit penser
à vous gens misent en ce moment pourquoi
parce qu'ils les belges entendent écrire
alors en tout cas ils ont l'air de bien
vivre leur saison on regarde cette
séquence
[Applaudissements]
genre ce sont des images qui font
plaisir oui et non oui les a vécus et
polenta aussi comme ça les images de
lier ces deux jours peut-être encore
plus rhône on le mange presque dans
quelques jours je sais un petit peu plus
avec moi plus je ne sais pas parce que
là ils montrent des scènes de finale
qu'en corée sans jamais monter c'est
quand même particulier
c'est très dur à obtenir une montée
c'est qu'un venus en deux jours alors on
va maintenant à quitter notre page
résultats pour passer à notre coup de
projecteur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui dans notre coup de
projecteur en prend la direction de
plaisir à l'équipe de handball de la
ville termine la plus belle saison de
son histoire par une victoire assurée de
monter pour la première fois en
nationale 3 les jaune et noir se sont
imposés dans le lors de l'ultime journée
contre draveil dans un match sans enjeu
le score 34 à 31 avec cette victoire
plaisir termine donc sa saison avec un
bilan de 20 victoires un nul et une
seule défaite on écoute le capitaine ça
représente énormément pour pour le
public pour le club les anciens du club
le tout les dirigeants les bénévoles les
petits enfin c'est vraiment vraiment une
grande famille c'est pour tout le monde
voilà c'est pas que nous c'est pas que
les 12 c'est vraiment un
un club qui a vécu ce moment là tout son
sens mais à quand une chose c'est de
faire la fête avec eux ce soir après les
festivités les plaisirs aux oraux ont
déjà les yeux rivés sur la saison
prochaine est l'objectif numéro 1 le
maintien on écoute le coach faut tout de
suite se remettre au travail parce que
va falloir tout au moins maintenir
l'année prochaine et puis travailler de
manière à pouvoir continuer à
à mener le projet et c'est de mener le
plus haut possible donc avec cette
affaire un petit mot sur la montée de
plaisir qui était dans votre championnat
nous faisons le championnat des coûts
déjà félicitations à ce groupe parce que
l'on sait que la montée de la
prénationale am3 c'est très compliqué il
y a qu une seule montée et bien souvent
on peut dire on entend de la part des
arbitres que le haut du classement de la
prénationale est plus fort que une la
bonne moitié basse
de la nationale 3 parce que c'est la
région parisienne et c'est assez
atypique il ya beaucoup de bons joueurs
dans la région parisienne jusqu'à des
anciens joueurs de l'équipe de france de
handball
ça va jusque là donc donc du coup
félicitations à eux parce que c'est un
championnat très très très dur on voit
bien un 20 victoires un nul une défaite
et sous pondère ils sont vraiment juste
derrière donc on n'a pas droit beaucoup
d'erreurs j'avais quatre points d'avancé
sur le second
c'est à dire deux victoires et donc
voilà festation à eux
pour victor gras gay ça fait six années
maintenant qu'il est au club
il a façonné l'équipe année après année
il a amélioré
en terme de qualité de jeu projet
défensif projet sur le jeu rapide en
améliorant par les joueurs poste par
poste et ils ont fini à chaque fois 2e
2e 2e 2e 3e qui ont eu une année il y
avait deux montées et a pas grand chose
et une année ça s'est joué au goal
avérage particulier but à l'extérieur
soit dernière journée donc là je suis
content pour eux parce qu'ils ont
tellement eu de déceptions à saper ses
13 ans qui est né en prénationale et ça
faisait quatre cinq ans qu'ils étaient
très proches d'obtenir la santé ouais si
ce même et donc voilà maintenant
je pense que ce groupe là quelque chose
à jouer en nationale 3 mais prochaine je
pense alors à ses très bons résultats du
plaisir handball il faut ajouter la
montée en fédérale 2 de l'équipe senior
de rugby de la ville de genlis plaisir
il ya également du tennis à haut niveau
dans la ville et du volley-ball avec les
garçons qui sont en nationale 3 la
question sur ce thème plaisir est elle
une vraie ville de sport oui ou non vous
votez oui non oui oui vous est unanime
on va vous donner la parole jean vice
aussi parce que c'est vrai dit de spa si
je dis non non non mais moi connaissent
un faux nez ça parle à travers le rugby
la ville de plaisir à travers le rugby
est une fille il faut connaître quelques
plaisirs déjà des installations
sportives dans les disciplines que que
vous avez cités qui sont magnifiques qui
sont purement magnifique donc déjà pour
pouvoir travailler
c'est dans des conditions quasiment
idéale et puis on a quand même un énorme
soutien de notre municipalité
je vois à travers le rugby et moi je
peux pas parler pour les autres
disciplines maintenant le rhodium on a
un gros souci au niveau de notre
municipalité que ce soit aussi bien vous
avez 4 122 licenciés si je me trompe pas
ou bien c'est certainement ont vu
certains je sais qu'elle avait autour de
400 l'un des plus gros clubs de la ville
il ya vingt sept clubs
c'est l'un des bureaux à huy
oui parce que cela se joue à quinze
autres buts non mais une belle école de
rugby
il ya des jeunes qui gaze bien il ya des
bons résultats
les deux équipes seniors dont celle qui
préserve a perdu yves algérien demi
finale championnat de france et puis
elle nous jouerons nous avec eux
l'équipe première les huitièmes de
finale du championnat de france dimanche
à wil contre ris orangis
donc c'est vrai que voilà le travail
effectué toute la saison pour nous avec
frédéric jardin
et moi même en équipe première c'est le
résultat d'un travail sur deux années et
derrière comme je vous disais la
municipalité et haffner donc
effectivement oui je suppose que le
plaisir est une ville très sportive
alors robin ya six mille sept cent vingt
licenciés sur la saison 2015 2016 on n'a
pas les saisons là les chiffres de la
saison 2016 2017 pour 31 mille habitants
il ya 27 clubs je le disais précédemment
est ce que ce sont de bons chiffres
voilà pour une ville comme plaisir j'ai
l'impression mais c'est pas forcément le
quantité qui quand je pense que c'est la
qualité donc c'est en a grand nombre de
licenciés c'est bien c'est on a un
nombre moyen mec mais comme des gens les
installations sont bien et donc de
niveau qualité générale est bonne ça
c'est une autre mesure des ce qu'est ce
que c'est une ville très sportive mix
entre le qualité et le nombre de jours
longtemps que l'on juge plus peut-être
sur les gros clubs que sur un
éventuellement le l'inconvénient sait on
assez on investit trop dans la qualité
va dire oui on laisse pour y laisser
tomber le score peu plus amateurs de
simplement impliquer le maximum de gens
donc on dans une des dernières émissions
n'avait parlé du du de la course à pied
la quantité des gens qui font la course
à pied donc ça c'est un sport et peu
d'investissements et beaucoup
participation pour le rugby pour
des scores qui se joue dans les gymnases
il faut un peu plus d'investissement
l'investissement donc une ville sportive
ce monsieur sur les deux qualité et
quantité je pense ça se mesure également
peut-être hélène au niveau de la
politique de la ville la ville de
plaisir a décidé en 2002 de mettre en
place une politique sportive avec
l'enseignement des avait des activités
des écoles élémentaires et maintenant
voit ces jeunes qui sont arrivés du coup
à maturité qui sont maintenant dans les
clubs de plaisir y en a 80 % qui sont
restés à plaisir pour aider leur club à
monter à jouer le haut du classement
c'est la ville finalement qui donne le
tempo
peut-être au niveau de la politique se
sont sorties de la ville est forcément
car plus les bons résultats dans farol
forcément si c'est une politique d entre
guillemets le plus le plus jeune âge
voilà ça intéresse les jeunes y
grandissent dans la discipline il se
découvre des talents ils ont envie de
rester ils ont envie de performer en
plus ya toute l'infrastructure qui va
bien c'est louis les choix les choix
faits par la mairie la ville et cetera
c'est c'est ce qui donne aussi voilà les
résultats et et on voit dans même
plusieurs disciplines dont on a des
champions on a des clubs qui montent on
a des victoires donc forcément c'est
c'est important genre vous le ressentez
vous dans votre club
cet attachement à la ville les enfants
ont grandi finalement olivier des clubs
locaux par le club local
ah oui tout à fait nous avons eu un club
de rugby qui a à peu près j'irais plus
de 80 % de joueurs issus de
de l'école de rugby et de la ville de
plaisir qui habitent dans le coin après
basse et la moyenne 80% ouais c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment un club en club
entre guillemets famille c'est à dire
c'est vraiment des joueurs qui évoluent
ensemble depuis de nombreuses années et
qui sont issus du club il ya très très
peu de gens de l'extérieur quoi comme
c'est vrai qu'on voit vraiment que à
travers ça la ville la ville intéresse
les jeunes sportifs à rester et propose
aussi justement de belles installations
de beaux clubs c'est ça aide tout ça et
avec ça je pourrais rajouter parce que
c'est vrai que on dit on dit plaisir
mais même les yvelines avec général avec
le golf le vélodrome fait il ya eu de
très très belles installations comme
plaisir est le reflet un petit peu du
département alexandre plaisir peut-elle
avoir des deux meilleures équipes encore
mieux classé à la loupe
416 1000 euros par an aux associations
sportives finalement c'est pas si énorme
71 me 350 euros de subventions pour le
rugby un jour miss paris ce que s'est
passé je ne sais pas faire
est ce que c est ce que c'est suffisant
pour avoir un club par exemple comme
comme plaisir qui va monter en fédérale
2 la saison prochaine qui va jouer
contre des gros morceaux qui ont des
budgets à plus d'un million d'euros
est-ce que c'est suffisant non je pense
pas sincèrement je pense pas parce que
j'ai un peu une idée de ce que cela peut
coûter quand même en rugby et ça me
semble ça me semble ça me semble
insuffisant pour
voir sereinement le maintien la saison
prochaine par rapport aux
investissements qu'on va voir les autres
équipes c'est mon avis après il ya des
sports qui sont qui sont plus gourmands
qu d'autres je pense que pour le
handball c'est suffisant ce qui est
donné au club de handball mais je pense
que pour le rugby ça serait bien qu'ils
aient un peu plus après voilà c'est à
chaque sport de de se battre pour avoir
le plus d'argent possible près de la
municipalité et que le meilleur gagne
d'accord oui tout à fait pour être
entendu non mais bien sûr c'est normal
c'est tout à fait normal
il l'a très bien il l'a très bien dit le
niveau au dessus
on pourrait difficilement voir plaisir
un jour dans le top 14 14 14 un autre
monde l'a déjà rien arrivé déjà en
fédérale une ou même la pro d2 s'il sait
déjà il faut lui autant d'entrées
d'argent pour on n'est plus au monde
plus on monte plus le plus le fossé est
grand entre les régions et donc c'est là
on parle on parle d'une autre
notre monde complètement mais c'est vrai
que
/ / plaisir ce que ce que disait
alexandre au niveau du rugby c'est pas
simplement l'argent municipal c'est
aussi les partenaires aller chercher
d'autres partenaires à les intéresser
d'autres partenaires parce que le niveau
va être différent parce que plus de
sponsors voilà vous partenaires une
partenaire lorsque j'en saurai plus des
partenaires les épargnants saurai que
donc et c'est vrai que c'est tout un
travail du club là après on bénéficie au
niveau du rugby pour la saison prochaine
je pense de la restructuration des
poules qui auront passé à 12 ça va
peut-être permettre aussi d'avoir cette
saison là
peut-être un petit peu facilement
sportive sportivement plus facile à se
maintenir alors on va passer maintenant
notre focus du jour il concerne les jeux
olympiques 2024
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les jeux olympiques 2024 seront peut
être attribuée à paris donc en 2024 le
cio est passé lundi 15 mai sur les
différents sites yvelinois pour les
évaluer la commission s'est notamment
rendu à lille de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines pour repérer le
futur emplacement du stadium de bmx une
structure qui sera implanté un peu moins
de 400 mètres de l'actuel piste située à
côté du vélodrome nationale
on écoute les réactions il ya
effectivement un bébé bmx qui est juste
à côté sauf que pour les épreuves
olympiques qui a des parcours qui sont
beaucoup plus longs avec j'irai un
circuit et ce site aujourd'hui le bmx
actuelle ne permet pas de réaliser ces
parcours
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle l'île
de loisirs et plus particulièrement cet
espace va être aménagée d'une manière
provisoire
ce ne sera pas une installation
permanente donc pour l'entraînement ça
représente
après deux superbes outils sur lesquels
on peut diversifier justement les
entraînements ce qui peut les aider à
progresser encore un petit peu plus
maintenant sur le fait voilà de la
compet de la faire sur une autre piste
une façon ils seront prêts quoi qu'il
arrive vraiment que ce soit sur celle là
ou sur une autre encore une fois le job
ce sera le même
la nouvelle piste sera donc sans toit
pour permettre aux télévisions de filmer
détail qui n'avait pas été évalué lors
de la construction la piste serait
également légèrement trop petit et trop
dangereuses notamment départ la pire le
pire dans l'histoire c'est que la piste
a été rénové en 2015 pour la rendre plus
présentable pour les jo
la question sur ce thème la construction
d'une nouvelle piste à côté de
l'ancienne et est ce que c'est une faute
professionnelle faute professionnelle ou
pas la construction
la nouvelle piste juste à côté de
l'ancienne la construction de la base
vous êtes vous d'accord c'est
occasionnel robin professionnels de le
construire cette obligation de
construire est ce que ça ne vous
professionnel qu'on était arrivés
abandonnait 1 installations déjà
construites
je pense pas c'est forcément de faute
professionnelle non plus je connais pas
les frais d'investissement mais quand
c'est les jeux olympiques
la somme d'argent qui investit là dedans
tellement important une autre piste a
construit sa va pas casser le budget des
jeux olympiques meilleur oui c'est c'est
plus que dommage meilleur sinon c'est le
fait de l'avant rénové en 2015 pour lui
c'est ça que 2015 c'était pour les
chiots s'était pas
en vue d'autres choses présentées pour
les présenter mais si on présente
quelque chose qui ne l'est pas
présentables canal déjà en plus c'est
vraiment vers attendent la décision et
chassant ses 1.1.2 l'occasion pour avoir
les yeux des gens premièrement et puis
deuxièmement ça veut dire que nos impôts
il passe dans ce consécutivement de
construction parce que c'est pas
l'argent uniquement des géo qui vont
être alloués à ça les impôts locaux vont
y être et moi je serai habitants je
serais curieux de savoir que l'on
gaspille mon argent 2 pour là pour la
même chose deux fois de suite quoi
espérance est quand même une suspension
de bien sûr mais elle n'est pas à 100%
ça c'est une évidence
ça m'étonnerait qu'elle soit 100% mais
moi je suis je suis pas expert de piste
de bmx mais le regarder l'écran par
rappo pouces piste bmx qu'on avait ou
dernier jeu de la paix séparée évident
qui n'est pas au top et pas de ne pas de
couleur c'est que du gris tandis que les
autres seuils multicouleurs arrive
également de l'aménagement
si vous n'êtes tribune également il est
très dur il va falloir très grande
moi quand je les suis pas expert mais
regarde en regardant ça je me dis oui
c'est pas à la hauteur des jeux
olympiques
est-ce qu'il faut gens peut-être donner
plus la parole aux acteurs du terrain
qu'ils connaissent finalement peut-être
mieux le bmx que les les instances qui
ont qui avait subventionné cette
première piste de bmx
alors les acteurs du terrain'' pour moi
les acteurs du terrain les attendus
c'est une sélectionneur sexuelle par le
sportivement c'est à dire que pour eux
sportivement le fait d'avoir déjà cette
piste c'est bien le fait d'en avoir une
autre
pour encore mieux donc ils réfléchissent
sportive un mois je trouve la musique
actuelle pourrait servir de piste
d'entraînement l'a nommé sera plus voilà
d'accord mais c'est bien c'est bien
c'est sûr sportivement c'est très bien
voilà c'est très bien sportivement
maintenant c'est un petit peu mois pour
moi je trouve que c'est un petit peu un
scandale c'est une énorme faute
professionnelle parce qu'il devient work
m
un cahier des charges qui demande qui
demande une piste de bmx pour les jeux
olympiques fait comme ça comme ça comme
ça là on fait une ovation en 2015
on n'est pas capable on n'est pas foutu
de se mettre aux normes par rapport aux
jeux olympiques c'est qu'alain pas le
tournoi de pêche qu'on va faire c'est
les jeux olympiques
1 donc c'est quand même pour moi une
énorme faute professionnelle c'est
peut-être c'est l'organisation
paris 24 qu'il n'est pas expliqué là je
pense quand même là on remet en cause
carrément le système légion enfin je
sais pas ça me confirme si ça veut dire
si le fonds si le fonds sortis d'un
repas en disant ah ben chagra a été
sectionné le tour aujourd'hui
allez bon mais tu te laisses vous la
voulez aurélia sur une fois lever le
toit
je pense pas faut être sérieux je pense
quand même qu'il aurait pu il aurait pu
demander avant en 2015 exactement ce
qu'ils demandent ce que ce que les jo
préconise préconisé pour l'organisation
pas le faire déjà vrai dire on n'en
refus d'un côté et tout ça c'est un
petit peu gros quand hélène après le
comité olympique aurait pu s'adapter
peut-être au site
avec son toit voilà il aurait pu adapter
peut-être les caméras pour geforce je
pense que quand tu sais ce que c'est
finalement à nous adapter à eux où
est-ce que c'est au comité s'adapter aux
réalités du terrain ça va coûter de
l'argent en plus oui sans parler de de
l'argent que ça va coûter
je pense que vos niveaux des géo il ya
des exigences par discipline
elles doivent être les mêmes pour tout
le monde donc
je pense pas que le comité ait besoin de
s'adapter oui mais pas sur des longues
heures de piste ou pas sur des histoires
de toi qui empêche
je sais pas de la louis de filmer ou la
bonne présentation des jo non je pense
que on ne peut pas adapter ce genre de
choses fanta s'adapter pas ce genre de
choses la largeur la texture de l'air
d'avoir on est obligé si on veut si on
veut les jeux olympiques on peut pas
leur dire ab goûter si vous n'êtes pas
contente d'aller voir ailleurs
c'est ce niveau y aller ailleurs donc là
le problème c'est qu'on n'a pas le choix
sur le veut on est bien obligé de dire
amen à tout ce qu'ils demandent et si
demain on en recause cela côté église à
un petit peu trop courte qu on aime tant
mais je fasse quand même que
sérieusement il veille à dieu il fait
beau y avoir quand même un cahier des
charges et qui n'a pas ou qui n'a pas
été suivi et si ça n'a pas été donné par
le comité d'organisation c'est encore
plus grave parce que là c'est quand même
de l'argent public est parti en fumée
et à côté également aussi fait polémique
c'est le côté éphémère genlis de de la
piste mais parce qu'elle devrait être
dévoilé à planter la tente et à la fin
la fin de la compétition un an après
parce qu'on la laisse ou pas finalement
sportivement comme là je rejoins tout à
l'heure sportivement comme je disais le
sélectionneur et dimensionner le 2ème
table parce que ce sera encore mieux
cotés pour la préparation
si on la construit pourquoi la démonter
pour entrepôts on va la donner à qui ils
voient la vente en valent à revendre le
mettre sur le bon coin où donc
elle a démonté ça permet d'utiliser le
terrain pour une traction et de
récupérer de l'argent par rapport à ça
moi je pense que je pense qu' il
faudrait la démonter parce qu étant
donné qu' on a déjà une ecclésiaux ça
sera 2024 et prochain on a le temps de
voir si on les a obtenus en 2024
je pense que la démonter ça permettra de
récupérer de l'argent sur l'utilisation
de ce sol d'une autre façon
bmx ou disait éloge du bmx s'est pas non
plus pour une soirée pour autre chose
alors c'est le moment de passer à notre
rubrique débats dans cette émission à
jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va continuer à parler des jeux
olympiques dans ce débat et plus
particulièrement d'un sport qui fait
couler beaucoup d'encre le baseball le
sport et sera de retour au genou lors de
la prochaine édition à tokyo en 2020 ce
sera un sport additionnel et non pas un
sport qui sera intégrée sur les
prochaines éditions
c'était une demande de la part des
organisateurs nippon du coup le baseball
sera en option pour les jeux olympiques
de 2024 si los angeles est sélectionné
pas de soucis mais si c'est la france
il y a très peu de chances que le sport
soit reconduit la question sur ce thème
le baseball doit-il être aux jeux
olympiques de 2024
en france oui ou non voter non vous êtes
unanime vgcd m'embêter sur cette
émission brebis moquettes coquettes le
spécialiste
oui c'est spécial non mais quand on
parle du bike polo autre chose moi je
pense les jeux olympiques c'est quand
même des jeux internationale et pour à
mon avis déjà hier le golf je vois pas
pourquoi le golfe
aux jeux olympiques est tellement d'
d'argent déjà tellement tournoi remonte
à il ya beaucoup de pays qui jouent au
golf donc je me contre délicieux mon
point mais bon et je suis certain que
tiger woods le golf
ils ont pas besoin de ça mais les petits
sports dreamhack et kiwis à 5 ces dix
pays dans le monde qui ont qu'il qui
jouent à ce sport là pourquoi pas le
mettre au japon parce que c'est un sport
national au japon pourquoi ne pas le
mettre ton diction aux états unis comme
ce pot 1 littaye pourquoi pas mes yeux
non les jeux olympiques c'est pour les
sports où il ya un minimum dix ans vingt
cinq ans pays qui vont participer sinon
on a juste n'importe quoi sans vous êtes
d'accord avec leurs robinets
oui un petit peu oui une fois d'accord
avec les britanniques
oui c'est vrai je crois que le baseball
c'est vraiment la discuter un petit peu
ça va c'est vraiment jouer aux états
unis à cuba au japon mais après ce qu'un
pas on sait qu'il a gagné finalement
mais ce que je crois qu'ils ont eu cinq
éditions et le cuba l'ont emporté 3 et
la corée du sud le japon et le japon
choix que c'est le dernier vainqueur et
ça a été il y aura levé à l'issue des
jeux olympiques 2008
c'est ça non je crois effectivement à
l'issue des jeux olympiques 2008 et au
japon il avait supprimé le baseball est
bon mais je vois là c'est ça ça concerne
que trop peu de pays pour que ce soit
vraiment représentatifs et et que ces
valeurs aux jeux olympiques quoi tout le
monde voit je dois jouer le jeu selon
vous alexandre taillefer
voilà le
finalement le même les américains ne
voudrait les états unis voudraient pas
joué le jeu en envoyant des équipes
réserves voire encore plus réservé des
jeunes tout simplement est ce que tous
on doit jouer le jeu peut être créer des
ligues un peu partout des ligues
compétitif pour remettre finalement le
sport jeux olympiques à part les
américains les autres ils jouent au jeu
sauf qu'ils n'ont pas le jeu quoi c'est
ça c'est ça la problématique donc à
partir du moment où les jo c'est quelque
chose d'universel le baseball ne l'est
pas donc c'est un sport qui n'a rien à
faire aux jeux olympiques
si demain c'est un sport qui devient
universel dans 50 ans entend 30 ans 20
ans peut-être plus tôt pourquoi pas mais
aujourd'hui c'est pas dans l'actualité
après on peut éviter éventuellement
faire de ce sport pour inviter dans un
pays qui est très populaire
enfin d'accord si par exemple pour moi
ça sans visa parce qu'il y aurait dû y
aura du monde il y aura des spectateurs
parce que faire ça en france pourra voir
personne je vois pas l'intérêt voilà
donc pour moi elles sont de l'eswi à
paris non cela permettrait pas de
booster peut-être le nom de licence il y
en a quinze mille en france si elle est
joueuse rapide en france sa peau était
encore plus le nombre de licenciés oui
c'est sûr mais le temps qu'on est
vraiment l'impact significatif ça va
prendre combien d'années je suis pas sûr
que il faudrait déjà que les gens soient
minimes en intéressés pour avoir envie
d'aller voir
les matchs de suivre ça et puis après ça
commence à s'inscrire commencé à
pratiquer et développer ça prendrait
trop de temps trop de temps fait ça va
forcément augmenter nombre de licenciés
mais je pense à ses pions mais la pole
dance aux jo
forcément ça ça boostera tout de suite
vous avez assez spécifique selon vous
mais toi ça le problème est le même dans
toutes les disciplines après la pole
dance est un peu différent je pense que
c'est pratique et dans plus de pays à
plus de licenciés je pense pas plus de
dix ans et plus de pratiquants de paul
que de baseball en france donc déjà et
puis beaucoup plus de pays wiki ou la
pole et déjà déjà implanté déjà pratiqué
au revoir robin pour les soucis
également d'infrastructures à ce que
c'est lui le point noir en finalement du
dossier on n'a pas de stade de baseball
en france il faudra forcément qu'on soit
là ou sinon il ya les cougars de mon
team retenue qui ont proposé qu'on fasse
des matches sur leur stade jean maréchal
à montcenis
est ce que c'est une bonne idée
finalement pas jeux de proposer la honte
de jouer sur scène paul chaîne sport où
il ya beaucoup de pays qui participent
c'est déjà un point et deuxièmement oui
quand on investit dans des frais
d'infrastructure on va pas on a vu
d'autres jeux olympiques comme athènes
où il ya quasiment rien qu'il restait
tout est tombé dans les ruines
donc soit on investit vraiment et soyez
logique du début à la fin mais on peut
pas bricoler inventé un truc en serait
là bas et je connais pas le stade dans
le règlement l'écran bay pour le
transformer au niveau 1 2 jeux
olympiques
je pense qu'il ya un investissement
important il serait ravi son de gland
corps la foule après structure présente
notamment dans les quelques cinq ou six
lieux oui ils peuvent installer ça mais
il faut être
il faut être un peu réaliste on les aime
tant des investisseurs un peu vos
lanternes le fera et long terme mais ça
coûterait moins cher qu construire un
nouveau stade à plusieurs millions
d'euros oui certainement mais il faut
voir du début à la fin
moi je compte on arrête à mon avis on
arrête la réflexion avant on va pas
faire du vélo donc la question ne se
pose pas adapt adaptation de stades
existants nouveau stade non on va pas
jusqu'à là de toute façon non mais la
piste du mx oui vous êtes vous remis ses
installations du baseball ici à montigny
voilà quand on voit qu'il ya déjà des
sites olympiques
ici le vélodrome le bmi clan avaient par
l'accueil des rayons sur le golf c'est
surtout par rapport à l'investissement
que cela représente et au retour que ça
peut avoir je pense pas et je voulais
les pays qu'on a cité tout à l'heure les
états unis cuba le japon
ces professionnels chez eux chez nous
ces amateurs et je crois mais en europe
on en parle et je sais mais c'est même
peut-être semi professionnel incertain
certains endroits mais mais c'est très
très peu traite un peu fréquenté chez
nous donc ce serait un gros
investissement pour un petit retour mois
pour moi ça suffit déjà la piste de bmx
moi je pense encore
ces impôts banon mais c'est à dire c'est
ça c'est les coûts que cela va apporter
supplémentaire pour quel retour
on sait très bien que les jeux
olympiques agissant c'est peut-être à
chaque achat ne sais pas si ça fait tout
ça c'est nous deux est censée rapporter
va pas combler le trou financier pour la
construction d'un stade
c'est sûr que pour les clubs de baseball
pour les pratiquants de baseball c'est
leur intérêt il est là mais si on prend
un peu de recul et qu'on regarde
intérêts de la france déjà on sait très
bien que c'est très dur de revenir dans
ses sous sur djo que tu as fait très
longtemps que personne n'a gagné
d'argent non plutôt perdu énormément
dans un état de crise convient
mondialement je pense pas que c'est le
moment de faire des dépenses
supplémentaires avec on le sait dores et
déjà aucun en retour aucun bénéfice
financier rapidement tour de table
combien de chances d'avoir les jeux
olympiques ici en france le pourcentage
5% mais je pare brise et moi les
baseball à 0% en volume aux hommes
jouent ou 0 00 % vous est unanime c'est
la fin de cette émission merci nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve le jeudi 8
juin pour un nouveau numéro de six ans
par les sports à bientôt sur téléphiles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]